- Part of this video was
sponsored by Google Domains.
This is a US government warehouse
that sells almost
anything you can imagine.
Blueberries, steel, cigarettes,
limestone, a standard bullet
and even some things you
don't want to imagine.
I also see you have domestic sludge there.
(Dr.Place laughs)
This is domestic sludge.
- So, when you flush your toilet
and it goes through the sewer
and it goes into a
wastewater treatment plant,
the first step is to get rid
of all the solid material.
We took that, dried it down,
so it's a nice fine powder.
I wouldn't recommend smelling it.
- What is the purpose of all this stuff?
Why are they selling it
and why is it so expensive?
Does it ever feel like you're
living inside a sci-fi story
or something?
- [Dr. Choquette] You know,
I've been here for a long time,
so I don't think it from that perspective,
but I should say yes.
- [Derek] The science
fiction element to me
is like there's someone
thinking about that?
- Yeah.
- There's someone collecting that?
It seems so fictional.
Like why should a place like this exist?
There are apple leaves and
peach leaves, oyster tissue,
bars of zinc metal, carbon
dioxide in nitrogen.
In these vats of liquid nitrogen,
there are samples of marine animals.
- Mussel samples, dolphin
samples, whale samples.
Birds as well, bird tissue
And some human tissue as well.
- [Derek] But perhaps the
weirdest thing they sell
is something really mundane.
Peanut butter.
- It looks like a peanut butter.
It is peanut butter.
It's creamy.
- [Derek] It's probably
the most expensive jar
of peanut butter in the whole world.
- Well, we essentially
pay for a company to make
generic peanut butter.
We might have 2000 jars
of generic peanut butter.
And what we do is we then go through
and measure the fats in these jars
and figure out how much of
various compounds are in there.
And we actually then slap on a label
and provide a certificate at the end.
- Have you ever eaten some
of this peanut butter?
- All of these things are
not for human consumption
because I don't know if
I could actually tell you
how old it is, but it's old enough
that you probably don't want to eat it.
- How much does it cost?
- These are not sold at
commercial grade prices.
So, this jar of peanut
butter is not $3.99 cents.
This jar, I believe, is
around a thousand dollars.
This is not something that
would be viable for you
to make your peanut butter
and jelly sandwich with.
- [Derek] An ordinary jar of peanut butter
costs less than $5.
And on the label you
can see the ingredients
and the amounts of different nutrients
like protein, fats, sugar, and sodium.
Those values have been
measured by the manufacturer
using different machines
and analytical techniques.
But how do you know those
results are accurate?
Well, this is where the government's
standard jar of peanut butter comes in.
It is mixed up so carefully and thoroughly
that each jar contains
exactly the same substance.
- We take great pains at
homogenizing these things.
Make sure it's consistent.
- [Derek] Then scientists
at the National Institute of
Standards and Technology, NIST,
take years to painstakingly
identify the quantities
of all the different
compounds in the peanut butter
with specified uncertainties.
This peanut butter is then known
as a standard reference material or SRM.
They sell these perfectly characterized
SRM samples of peanut
butter to researchers
and manufacturers so they can
calibrate their equipment.
Essentially, the buyer
knows that their equipment
is working properly if,
when they run the standard peanut butter,
they get the values NIST
supplies on the certificate.
- We've spent a lot of time
to make sure that we're
confident and, you know,
we can spend years studying
the amount of fat in here
and trying to figure out
exactly what those numbers are.
- [Derek] So what you're paying for
is not really the peanut butter,
it's the knowledge of exactly
what is in the peanut butter.
- And so this is what
really drives the cost
of a standard reference material
is our ability to assert the truth.
We produce what I call truth in a bottle.
- You might think, why does it matter
that the label on my
peanut butter is accurate?
But it is way more than
the things on the label
that NIST measures.
Peanut butter actually
contains naturally occurring
aflatoxins.
They're are carcinogen
which can cause liver cancer
and they're produced by
fungi on the peanuts.
So if your peanut butter is made from
a bad batch of peanuts,
you want the factory
to be able to accurately detect
elevated levels of aflatoxins.
And they're able to do that
because the standard
peanut butter contains
a known level of
aflatoxin that can be used
to calibrate their equipment.
Will the FDA like sample peanut butters
and look for aflatoxin?
- A lot of times you actually
have commercial laboratories
that measure it in accordance to the FDA.
The FDA may encourage them
to use a reference material,
standard reference material,
to make sure they're
getting the right numbers.
FDA may not be handling it themselves.
- [Derek] There are different challenges
to measuring the components
of different foods.
Fine powder, for example,
is easier to characterize
than goopy peanut butter.
So it's helpful to have
a standard material
that closely matches the target
in composition and consistency,
but it's also impossible
for NIST to characterize
every different type of food.
- We're not gonna make a trout and a perch
and salmon material,
all these different,
with the same numbers.
We're kind of grab an average
fish and kind of treat that.
So if you're measuring it in other fish,
you can usually use it as a surrogate.
- [Derek] So you have a standard trout?
- [Dr. Place] Correct, yes.
- [Derek] Tell me about Meat Homogenate.
(Dr. Place laughs)
- It is a mixed meat product
that has been mixed thoroughly,
been ground into a very fine particle,
and packed into a very nice tin.
- Why do you mix like chicken and pork?
Why not just have like
a chicken reference,
a pork reference?
- We never do this by ourselves.
We always work with these
industry companies and say,
"Hey what kind of mixes do you need?"
And then we request that kind
of material to be blended
- [Derek] For a reference
material to be useful,
It doesn't have to be the exact material
a manufacturer wants to characterize.
It just has to be close enough.
NIST sells around 30 different food items
that are spread around
their food triangle.
At the corners of the triangle
are a 100% carbohydrate, a
100% fat, and a 100% protein.
So, based on their mix of
these three macro ingredients,
all foods fall somewhere on this triangle.
And to characterize each
one, you would want to use
the closest standard reference material.
- If you're trying to do
your measurements and tell,
you know, a regulatory authority
that I'm making, you know,
a food that's a kibble,
but I'm measuring it
against peanut butter,
they're gonna be saying,
"Well, that peanut butter
has a wildly different fat content."
So what we wanna give them
is something, a matrix, that
looks as much as possible
as what they're used to dealing with.
- [Derek] They even have
a standard diet mix.
- This is called typical diet.
Through surveys, they identified
what the average American
eats and they purchased it
all and they blended it all up
and then they freeze dried
it into a nice fine powder.
It's like a light gray
powder and this represents
all the nutritional components
that an average American would consume.
So it represents the sugar content,
it represents the proteins
that you might have,
any vitamins you might have,
any fats you might have
is all in a little jar
that we puree up.
- [Derek] In total, NIST has nearly 1300
standard reference materials.
- This is our warehouse.
And so it's an approximately
20,000 square foot warehouse
in which we store all of
our inventory, our products,
the SRMs.
And so we are a business.
And so, what excites me about this,
being on the technical
side, is that I get to run
a 20 million business within
the federal government.
We sell about 30,000 units a year.
So each order is about three units.
Half of them are sold domestically
and half are sold to an
international audience.
- You can see all the
prices on on our website.
So it's shop.nist.gov is
the e-commerce storefront
for all these materials.
You can search for whatever you want.
You can search for peanut butter,
you can search for meat homogenate.
- [Derek] If I like
had a thousand dollars,
would you sell that to me?
- There is some control to who we sell to.
- I feel like this is
unfair like I'm a scientist.
If I got a thousand bucks.
NIST won't sell to just anyone,
but there are plenty of websites that do.
And this part of the video is
sponsored by Google Domains.
The easiest way to set
up an online business.
I have a shop where I
sell a product I invented
called Snatoms.
It's a molecular modeling kit
where the atoms snap
together magnetically.
You know, when I came up with
the name Snatoms back in 2015,
the first step was to
check if the domain name
snatoms.com was available.
If you have a good idea, you
should claim that domain name
as soon as you can.
It's like claiming a social media handle.
And Google Domains makes this easy.
I moved snatoms.com over to Google Domains
in just five minutes.
If you're building an
online store from scratch,
you can set up your whole website quickly
using Google Domains
simple templates and tools.
No coding required.
Now, with snatoms.com
set up on Google Domains,
I never have to worry about reliability.
It runs on Google Cloud's super
fast DNS infrastructure,
So the domain resolves lightning fast,
no matter where in the world,
your users are.
I also get peace of mind
from Google Domain's
security features, like
built in privacy protection
and two factor authentication.
Plus it automatically connects to tools
like Google Workspace or Google Analytics
to help me understand
and build the business.
So claim your own domain
name with Google Domains
starting at just $12 a year.
Go to domains.google/veritasium
to get 20% off
your first year.
I will put that link
down in the description.
So thanks to Google Domains
for sponsoring this part of the video.
But it's not just food
you need standards for.
- In the early 19 hundreds, like 1905,
there was a huge issue
with the quality of steel
that was being used in rail cars,
both locomotives and on the tracks.
It was that they knew
what they had to have
in the alloys to make it work.
It's just that all the
foundries that were making 'em
had no way to compare their
results of the material
they were making to
what every other chemist
knew they should be making.
And so Congress basically said
to National Bureau of
Standards at the time,
we need you to come up with
standard samples of steel
so that everyone can be on the same page.
And so what we did was we
made these standard steels,
analyzed them for all
their constituent parts,
so all the elements, the chrome, the iron,
the hydrogen carbon and
then distributed that
to the stakeholders, again the foundries,
so that they can inter compare
and compare their results
to a known source of steel.
And those were our very first
products that we produced.
- [Derek] Steel is still
one of the most important
SRMs at NIST.
What's your best selling product?
- Ah, those are called Charpies.
- Charpies?
- Yeah.
Okay, let's go look at a Charpie.
If you wanna test how strong your steel is
what Professor Charpy,
Mr.Charpy, came up with
was a test where he set up a pendulum
and at the end of a pendulum is a weight.
And if you pull that pendulum
up to a certain distance,
you can calculate it's potential energy.
At the bottom of the
swing of this pendulum,
the arc, is a vice.
And in the vice, is held
a standard piece of metal
called a Charpy.
And this has a little V-notch in it.
And so the idea is that
the pendulum comes through
and breaks this thing and then
it goes up on the other side.
And from that you can then
calculate the amount of energy
that it took to break this piece of steel.
Every company in the
United States and, frankly,
internationally, now has
to check their materials
against our Charpies annually
because the kind of steels they're making
are used in pipelines or they're
used in defense industries,
you know, for tanks, for things
that store nuclear waste.
So I have a joke.
I love things that break or
burn and these things break
and they have to break
and they can't reuse 'em.
So we sell a lot.
- How many would you sell in a year?
- We sell of those, of
all the different kinds,
we sell about 8,000.
- [Derek] Woah.
- Yeah.
- [Derek] NIST has been making these
standard reference materials
for over a century.
- This is what our very
first standard sample
number one looks like.
It is the real deal and it's
gray powder, it's limestone.
We are still making limestone
number one for 110 years.
And it is still so popular
that we sell 40 to 50
units a year of this.
- [Derek] Huh.
- Isn't that wild?
Very few companies are in
existence that are still selling
some of their original products and we do.
- [Derek] Most of the SRMs
we've discussed so far
are used for calibration.
But there's another class
of SRMs used for validation.
This means they're used
directly in industry tests
to ensure consistency.
An example is cigarettes.
- Evidently, smoking in
bed was a real issue.
You know, people were
like catching on fire.
And so there was a lot of regulation
as to how materials in your
mattress or in your sheets
or your bed clothes should
react to a combustible source.
And we produced some standard cigarettes
that, essentially, along
with the ASTM tests,
would help a manufacturer
determine how flammable
their furniture was or their
bed clothes or their mattress.
- [Derek] And for those
tests to be consistent,
the fires must be started
with a standardized NIST cigarette.
(siren blaring)
Fires started by smoking materials
are the leading cause of
death by fire in the home
in the US.
- Products like this, but
also with the regulations
that were in place and just
the educational campaigns
that went on have saved many, many lives.
- [Derek] But they also
have standards for things
you would never expect,
like a standard bullet.
- When a bullet is fired
through a gun, you know,
the rifling in the barrel
imparts marks to the bullet.
- [Derek] Forensic labs
then have to measure
these grooves to match the
bullet from the crime scene
to others fired by the suspected weapon.
But how do you know
they are accurately measuring the grooves?
- So this has standard marks on it.
They replicated a bullet.
Putting, I believe, essentially,
nano-indentations on it.
So very, very fine marks and
mapped it on this bullet.
They weren't fired through a
gun, they were manufactured.
- [Derek] So, to validate their equipment,
forensic labs can run the standard bullet
at the same time as a
bullet from a crime scene,
so they know their
measurements are accurate.
The goal of every standard
is to quantify something about the world,
something important that's
usually pretty hard to measure,
(vacuuming noise)
like house dust.
- In the early nineties, we
worked with maid services
and we got vacuum bags.
We went to hotels, went to motels,
took all the vacuum bags that
we got from all these hotels
and houses and everything,
mixed it together in a big pot,
so it's fully mixed, so every little jar
has the same number of chemicals,
has the same amount of material in it.
And then we measured everything in there.
And the reason why I
find dust is interesting
is 'cause dust is, from an
environmental point of view,
is a really good way
to tell what you and I
and our house are being exposed to.
- [Derek] Identifying
dangerous contaminants
is a big part of what these
standard reference materials
are for, which is why they have
several types of lead paint
or water from a glacier in Greenland.
- These are so rare that we
have to limit distribution
of one unit per customer per three years.
- Whoa.
Or dirt From New Jersey and Montana.
- We have a lot of soil samples.
They had the permission
to go into, essentially,
a contaminated industrial
site in Bozeman, Montana
and collect a bunch of rocks,
you know, five gallon pail
and bring 'em back and crunch 'em up.
And so these are certified, again,
for things like toxic elements.
- [Derek] Now the ultimate way to measure
what contaminants we're exposed to
is by what comes out of us.
Which is why NIST sells domestic sludge.
This is a record of what
has come out of our bodies
and down our sewers.
Researchers can examine
it for traces of toxins
or heavy metals.
Contaminants that many
of us may be exposed to
without knowing.
It's really about
environmental monitoring.
And next year they're coming out
with an actual human poop product.
- It's been in the news
quite a bit as, you know,
health is related to
your microbiome, right?
And we're starting to
understand that, you know,
your gut flora and what's in your stomach
is hugely important to your
health, your mental attitude,
just all sorts of things.
Fecal matter is an incredibly
difficult matrix to measure
and extract all the
different components out of.
And what this material will do is support
measurements of the metabolites.
And it'll be distributed as a
vial of powder, essentially.
- Do you know how much they got?
- A crap load.
(both laugh)
- [Derek] As our knowledge
of the world evolves,
so too do the standard reference materials
stored in this warehouse.
NIST is preparing to launch
its first living standard
reference materia next year.
The living cells will
be hamster ovary cells
that can produce monoclonal antibodies.
Monoclonal antibodies now
account for five of the 10
top selling drugs and
over 75 billion dollars
in annual sales worldwide.
When monkey pox started
spreading earlier this year,
one issue with diagnosing the disease
was that there were no
clear laboratory tests
to tell if someone was infected.
NIST was able to create a
positive control reference
of the monkey pox DNA in just 30 days.
This warehouse is a very
strange place to walk around.
So many disparate pieces of our world
carefully characterized,
labeled, and packaged up.
It's a reminder that behind the scenes,
invisible to most of us,
there are a group of
people working tirelessly
to ensure that things are
what we think they are.
When we eat peanut butter
on toast, we can be sure
the peanut butter contains
what the label says.
When your blood test comes back
with a cholesterol reading,
you know it was calibrated
with a standard.
And when you walk into
a steel-framed building,
you know the steel has
the appropriate structural
and mechanical properties
to hold up that structure.
Our world works because,
unbeknownst to most of us,
there is a small army of people
diligently checking that what is out there
aligns with the standards.
Even our poop.
(techno music)